the statement made after his arrest
Tiger Woods said quote what happened was
an unexpected reaction to prescribed
medications our doctor Tara Narula joins
us now Tara good morning good morning
all right
he listed his arrest report list for
medications what do we know about those
medications and how may have they
contributed to his condition so let's be
clear we don't know his medical history
so we don't want to speculate what we
know is in the police report and the
four medications that are listed the
first one Salak sex was what was written
down is not a known drug so it's unclear
if it was misspoken if it was Miss
written the next drug Vioxx which is a
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory drug was
taken off the market in 2004 for
increased cardiovascular risk he said he
hadn't taken it in over a year
the third drug was written as Toric's
again a little confusing as to what that
is we think it may be in and another
anti-inflammatory medication similar to
a vioxx class drug not approved in the
United States at toric octave and then
the last drug vicodin a scheduled two
narcotic a combination of hydrocodone
and acetaminophen or Tylenol now that
that go ahead well the breathalyzer test
came back negative for alcohol when the
story was first reported they said that
the officer smelled alcohol that he was
belligerent that now appears certainly
not the case what could have caused a
slurred speech well we know that vicodin
common side effects can be sedation
lethargy confusion impairment of mental
and physical abilities so clearly this
could have been a result of vicodin we
don't know how much he took what the
dose was how often when it was last used
these effects are particularly
pronounced if someone is starting this
kind of medication the dose is being up
titrated or it's being used with other
CNS or central nervous system depressant
meds like benzos in particular the
precautions on this medication vicodin
or any opioid state that you need to be
cautious when driving because it can
impair mental and physical abilities and
that you should only drive if you're
tolerant to the medication or you know
how it will affect you and surety of
know well I mean again it's written on
the medication it should have been a
warning given by doctors so you know it
should be out there we clearly need to
do a better job at educating people
about this vicodin is addictive it is
addictive and and this is the big
picture I think here needs to be on the
opioid epidemic let's not focus so much
on Tiger let's focus on the fact that
250 million prescriptions for opioids
written into the
1391 people dying a day in this country
of opioid overdoses and I think the
Surgeon General said it well in 2016
let's not call this a moral failing or
character flaw let's call it a chronic
brain disease when we're talking about
addiction it needs to be treated with
empathy and compassion well said thank
you for any my camera